I guess let's start with the the single
mom and like a single dad perspective
and like why why that's a different um
why why people should approach that
differently in relationships sure sure
how many kids do you have two okay and
they're in elementary school are they
high school or Elementary or elementary
and middle okay and they came from a
marriage or yep same father nope so two
different fathers yep okay so I guess
the question you're asking is why is
that a red flag if I understood it
correctly um yeah why is that a red flag
and then why is it okay for you like I
mean do you look at yourself the same
way that you look at as a single mother
if you're a single father no um do you
see men and women as the same do you see
men and women as equal in in some ways
um I mean start with that so in what
ways you see men and women as
different um I mean I think that they
should bring this same things to the
table you know I want somebody who is um
confident successful great at
communicating like those everything
should be reciprocated in a relationship
when it comes to um emotional capacity I
guess the question is is do you see
differences between men and women
because I mean you're you're kind of
describing the kind of guy that you want
to be yeah but I mean biologically yes
okay okay so um biologically I guess we
can start with that because you know
that women birth to Children which don't
do so that does a number on a person's
body doesn't
it um sure so there's one difference
between men and women so to kind of dive
down the rabbit hole of like the single
mom we'll get in the friendships with
friends and men and female friends and
the tattoos in a little bit as well too
but um there are differences between men
and women and when it's convenient what
I'll often hear is well if you say that
men should probably stay away from
single moms but you're a single dad with
a kid how is that is that any different
right like why do you get a pass on that
and the truth of matter is is that I
don't think guys really do get a pass on
that I think guys get
criticized oh dogs found something
interesting outside a squirrel maybe um
so guys so guys don't necessarily get a
pass you know in that regard because
women tend to disqualify men pretty
rapidly uh for a number of reasons and
one of them you know can be that they've
already got a a child um but
I guess the easiest way for me to to
Enlighten the ladies that are watching
and the ones on the panel also is that
um when a woman's got kids in tow from a
prior relationship and in your case
you've got two different kids from two
different fathers that brings extra
levels of complexity into a man's life
that he wouldn't necessarily deal with
if she didn't have kids for example
you've got two baby daddies you're going
to have two baby daddy drama you're
going to be dealing with that and I'm
going to have to hear about that I'm
also going to put myself in a position
where I essentially cuck old myself
where I am
now in a place where I have
responsibility to a child that isn't
mine doesn't have my last name doesn't
have my DNA there's no benefit to me but
I don't have generally speaking any
authority over that child and what men
typically find which is a different
experience that women don't usually
understand until they're a sister to a
guy that's dating a single mom or a
mother to a son that's dating a single
mom but they don't usually see this but
the difference is is that women want the
Authority off over your kid but they
don't want the responsibility to it
whereas the other way around guys tend
to find themselves in a position where
they have the responsibility they're
paying for meals we got to go to
Chuck-E-Cheese rich is paying the bill
we're going to go skiing Rich you know
cuts a chuck all this sort of stuff is
is coming off my end but I don't have
any authority over those kids because
when then when they they'll go and not
feel good about something they might
throw a little hissy fit something
doesn't go that their way Mom will swoop
in you know Mama Bear comes in protects
the children I'm not saying that these
women don't deserve love they don't
deserve a relationship I'm just telling
guys that are following my content that
are out there putting a dent in the
universe doing something chasing
Excellence it's far better for them to
entertain women without children than it
is to entertain women with children does
that make sense wouldn't that be exactly
the same the opposite way though too
no why because I didn't push a football
through my body I'm loaded I'm in great
shape men's value goes up typically as
they get
older but regardless of
that you if you take away your success
you're still a single father whether
it's yeah there's no that's a factor of
course however you're still talking
about a baby mama that I'm signing up to
deal with for the rest of my life I'm
gonna have to my life is going to have
to revolved around that in some capacity
and I don't have kids got it so um
Jordan the custody Arrangement you have
with the kids how does that work out do
you have them every other week is it yep
every other week yep okay so it and it's
the same with both fathers yep so you've
got a week on with both the kids and
then a week off with both the kids and
then they go to the respective fathers
and they come back to you yep sorry got
it yeah so that's so that's not normal
right like women get about 80% of the
custy orders which means that they're
with the kids most of the time like the
average deal that that that guys get in
most scenarios is they'll see their kids
every other weekend and like a Wednesday
night for dinner and then the moms have
the kids most of the time so in Jordan's
case she's got them 50/50 right which is
a little bit different so in most guys
scenarios like as soon as they're
dealing with a single mom the vast
majority of the time they've got the
kids most of the time now if I'm a
father and I've got kids chances are on
a balance of probabilties that I'm going
to spend more time raising your kids
then I am going to be around my kids so
that's another detriment as well too
that's a benefit that women experience
when they're with fathers that have
children I'm not saying that you have to
choose a father with children you can
also make a decision not to deal with a
guy that's got kids that's entirely
plausible right I think what doesn't
make sense to me is you're not
understanding that it's a big thing for
either a man or a woman to take that on
understand it's different because women
don't take responsibility of a man's
kids right how they just don't how can
you say that well we can use um well
nursery rhymes would be a great example
there's stories like Cinderella for
example where there's always the evil
stepmom there's no Nursery rhy there's
no story there's no Elementary story in
Disney where there's the evil stepfather
it's always the evil stepmom because
it's based on reality women don't
typically have much interest in a man's
child they just don't whereas men are
more than willing to swoop in man's
child I'm just saying
I I know about Cinderella I know about a
lot of fairy tales I is is there one
fairy tale one Disney story where
there's the evil
stepfather it doesn't it's not a fairy
tale Talk Tale I'm talking about reality
of I know but these are all based on
real
life I'm talking about is real life too
and so like for example I have this like
long time childhood friend and and I
actually have had multiple friends in
this position where they actually have
very successful careers um they're doing
really well they're single they start
dating a guy with three
kids they move in with these guys they
take on the responsibility of basically
being a stepmom they're taking these
kids to practices they're going to
conferences I mean they're doing all of
the things and from what I can see I
mean in a lot of these cases and I do
fault the women too because I feel like
they're not holding these guys to the
right standards however like they don't
have a ring on their finger no okay no
so I feel like they choice not to deal
with a guy with kids though why are they
choosing to deal with a guy with kids
yeah and men have the choice to deal
with a single mom or not but what you're
saying is it's different for men to take
that on than it is for women and what
I'm saying is I mean it might be it
might be different but it's still drama
that you're it's still drama on either
side okay so let's use my story versus
Jordan's story she's got two kids from
two different fathers I have one kid
from one I was married to her that's it
and there's no drama she's potentially
going to invite more drama into a man's
life by getting involved with her
because she's got a couple of kids from
a couple of different guys she's also
got two kids instead of one
kid you see what I'm saying here I feel
like we're
comparing finances and we're comparing
finances and um like having to support
these children and whatever but the
thing is it's the same perspective from
a women's perspective when women usually
support the children when a woman comes
into a man's children she assumes the
mother's role she moves into the house
she's cooking the dinner she's doing the
grocery she's taking the days off when
the kids are off sick from school she's
the back to school shopping she's
dealing with the agendas she's making
the lunches she's doing the laundry
she's also working and contributing 50%
to the bills so it does work both ways
in the perspective of if you want to say
avoid single moms it is a completely
valid the same way to say avoid single
dads Because you're going to come in and
not only are you mothering a child
that's not yours you also have to mother
a father a thousand per. okay look it
works both ways is what I'm saying yeah
I mean like you can use the angle that
it works both ways and what's good for
the goose is good for the ganner but
there's but there's a number of
significant differences and I don't
expect you know the gals to see it from
the men's perspective because you're
never going to see it from the man's
perspective because women's solipsistic
nature you just don't see it the the the
fact that you have to push just like how
you didn't see it from my
perspective no I completely see it from
your perspective but listen to this a
woman pushes a football out of her body
that changes her body a man does not do
that that is one significant difference
between men and women you do it with two
k arguing there's not a differ between
men and women no but you're saying that
that if you're advising men to stay away
from single moms you should basically be
saying the same thing for fathers
because yes it applies the other way
it's different and that's just one area
out of many that I've just explained to
you I mean you see the difference
right no I I see I see there is I see
that there's a difference between men
and women I agree that when a woman did
your body change when you had Sher um
not I I think I look great I mean I I
I'm not asking if you look great I'm
asking you did your body change
temporarily yeah temporarily yeah do you
look as good now as you did when you
were 23 I think I look better to be
honest with you okay how would you wrate
yourself on a scale of 1 to 10 like my
physical appearance overall or um I
don't know I've never done that your
physical appearance because you've
thought about that I've not thought
about that or or rated s on a scale so
I'm I'm going to pass on that one but I
will no I've never I mean if you're I
mean if you guys are in a chat group
where you're roasting dudes back and
forth and you're you're roasting them
because you think that they're lower
value than you so you must have some
idea what your value based on their
behavior and the things that they say
they
act let put a quick pause real quick
quick pause let's get to Jessica Jessica
to go ahead and pipe up
because um first time I was coming off
me it was um I also have a kid as well
um granted I still look very similar to
when I had my kid I still feel the
changes uh I remember the changes that
came with mine and then I do see
differences between men and women mostly
just
because it comes out of the mother in
all custody cases um that's kind of what
happened and a lot of that how those
Falls the majority is it that you know
the mom ends up taking the kid most of
the time than anything else that's also
creating the very lopsided of you know
the time with the dads and then
flip-flopping kind of how much
responsibity goes one way or the
other we lost you for a second or two
when you're quick what I'll say is I
would I would take turn your camera off
I think that'll help you speed your
connection up a little bit yeah I think
it's a connection issue yeah it's just
internet speed thing so bandwidth so for
the other ladies thanks for chiming and
Jessica so you think that men and women
when it comes to being a parent should
be treated identically no no one said
that I think it's worth a conversation
of course um you know but just to have
this like blanketed advice of like stay
away from Singles mom because it
introduces drama I think that can happen
on both sides I mean you that a woman
without kids doesn't bring the same
level of drama to a man's life and so
does Man without kids is what we're
saying let's look at this though I mean
the majority of sing par out there yeah
the majority of single parents are
mothers right so you have probably
double if not more single mothers out
there than you have single fathers and
so women are ultimately the sexual
selectors the pool that most men have to
choose from as far as women goes what
they're seeing right now is a lot of
single mothers in the dating pool just
because when you look at the way the
court system rules in child custody's
favor and Jordan yours yours is u a
little bit different than most
it's very rare to get 5050 joint custody
of of children in any state um you know
there are some 80% of the time I think
it's 83% of the time women are the
primary custodial caregivers to the
children so that means You' got the kids
more than I've got the kids which means
that men are putting themselves in a
position where they could potentially
spend more time raising another man's
children versus his own so even looking
at that even looking at that the time
that men generally spend raising kids
even if they are a single
father on a long enough timeline and the
balance of probabilities he's still
going to have more free time and more
time for relationships and dating than
your general run-of-the-mill single
mother will just purely based on
statistics I mean there's there's an
anomalies to that there always will be
um of course so I don't yeah I just
don't agree with like the the blanketed
advice there I mean I know my situation
is
not if if something is Right 80% of the
time is that a pretty good barometer on
how you should act like if we were if we
were gonna if I was gonna hand you a
parachute that only opened two out of 10
times are you still G to jump out of the
plane with it on well no
but apply
that every situation why why not why why
why are some situations okay to live by
the anomaly in other situations we
should live by the majority I'm not
saying live by it I'm saying I don't I
don't think that you should make that
like blanketed advice or just say like
you know write off all sing Single Moms
because it's going to introduce X Y and
Z to your life when it's certainly not
the case every single time but there's
nothing in this life that's the case
every single time that's the point you
treat every G why have such a Firm
Stance on because well if you have
options Jordan then you don't select a
single mom even single fathers don't
select single mom Ms if they have
options I didn't hear the first part of
what you said sorry if if you have
options you don't typically select a
single mom if you're a guy that's got
his head squared away you're going to
find a woman that doesn't have children
so rich if I'm someone
[Music]
who is self-reliant successful 35 I
don't have kids would you give me the
same advice and say that I should
probably avoid single fathers I would
well let me hit it from this angle if
I'm talking to you as my daughter I
would tell you the same thing stay away
from a guy that's got children in toe
from a prior relationship why is that
for your own
family right that's all I'm saying right
I'm saying but the reasons though are
different is what we're trying to get at
I'm mostly talking to guys when they're
reading my book when they're watching my
podcast and stuff like that and it's to
their advantage to find a woman that
doesn't have another man's seed in their
house and it's to my advantage to get
with a man on my own family with who
doesn't have that baggage as well if you
can get it but I suspect that your
option for getting that is much lower
than the available inventory of
successful older guys out there with
children so you don't think I can get a
guy that doesn't have kids you probably
could but all I'm saying is a guy like
me that has their [__] together has
options I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out